the Prime Minister's bid to sell her
brexit deal agrees with the EU yesterday
two MPs and of course the wider public
well let's speak note to the brexit
sector Stephen Barclay who joins us from
a Westminster studio mr. Barclays very
good morning the first time we've spoken
so I should say and congratulations on
on the new job and if anyone's going to
know the brexit secretary probably will
reports this morning that there's going
to be a TV debate between the Prime
Minister and the leader of the
Opposition on brexit what do you know
well the Prime Minister will be debating
with the leader of the Opposition this
afternoon in the House of Commons she
does so on a regular basis and what
she'll be doing is making the case
demonstrating that this is a good deal
it's a deal that respects the referendum
breaks or tears like me it delivers on
what we were looking for it introduces
for example a skills-based immigration
system it takes back control have a
money laws and borders and this is what
I campaigned for in the referendum it
delivers on that referendum results and
it's a very good deal for the United
Kingdom as a whole yeah we weren't
expecting the prime minister of course
to debate the leader of the Opposition
this afternoon because it's on the order
paper what we weren't expecting was to
hear that she wants to have a TV debate
with him because she ducked one of the
2017 election well I'm seeing plans for
that but obviously I know this is an
issue that you and sky as a whole have
campaigned on in terms of the general
election I'm sure your voice on that
will be heard in the coming days do you
think it's a good idea well it's a
decision to be taken into course I think
we have a lot of debates between the
Prime Minister and the leader or the
Opposition in the House of Commons but
what the whole cabinet needs to be doing
I'm looking forward to playing my part
in is making the case this is a deal
that delivers on the referendum and
we've had a very divisive period over
the last two years and it's now time
that we come together as a country we
move on and we deliver on this deal so
that working their business the
certainty it needs and also give
certainty to the EU citizens living in
the UK and to ask citizens living in
Europe the key question of course for
the prime minister right now is as you
know the arithmetic in the Commons
doesn't quite seem to be there for her
to get the deal through is how exactly
you persuade that there be 80 maybe 90
so of your own MPs that this deal is not
only the best deal but it's the only do
how is the Prime Minister going to
secure votes from people who seem so
implacably opposed to that which she's
agreed with you well you're absolutely
right this is the best deal and it's
also the only deal and EU leaders have
made that clear it's taken two years of
tough negotiation to get to this point
with a prime minister working day and
night to fight ok sallet how are you
going to sell have already stated they
would not vote for it in the form in
which it's in well some people rushed
out with their judgments very quickly
obviously it's looking at the withdrawal
agreement together with the political
declaration it's a package we need to
make the case the cabinet as a whole
needs to make the case all right now
don't pretend for a minute it's not a
challenging task given where the numbers
currently look but this is a good deal
that respects the referendum result and
we need to be clear with parliamentary
colleagues as to what the alternative
will be which will be massive
uncertainty from either no deal or no
brexit that's not in the interests of
their constituents it's not in the
interest of protecting jobs of giving
certainty to EU citizens in areas like
the NHS where we rely on EU citizens
alongside our own citizens and it
doesn't give security for our British
citizens in Europe but you did you said
you absolutely hit the nail on the head
there I mean what plenty of people are
looking for right now is clarity as to
to what happens if this deal is not
agreed to so simply put you know if one
of your parliamentary colleagues turns
around and says look what happens what
happens if the common says no to this
what use well we go into uncharted
waters and there be a huge amount I'm
sorry I'm sorry mr. Bartley that that's
surely not enough we're in on charity's
waters you must have it the very least
considered the possibility that on a
binary vote yes no with the numbers
against you as it stands right now that
you might not get the vote what happens
if the Commons says north well clearly
the government has been preparing for
different scenarios in terms of our new
deal planning but that's very
unattractive in terms of the uncertainty
that would give to business the impact
that would have investment on jobs and
what really matters here is thinking
about your
viewers their jobs their security what
the business community of our country
needs in terms of its investment
decisions and we have a deal on the
table it's the only deal as you say
which respects the referendum result
that brexit ears like me campaigned for
that allows us to put an end to freedom
of movement to have control over not
sending vast sums of money to the EU so
it delivers on what brick city is like
me campaigned for but it avoids the
uncertainty of the alternative which is
no deal no bricks it and that is what
parliamentarians need to reflect because
you said it there the alternative is no
deal so if the Commons says no no deal
is what's going to happen well this is
the only deal on the table European
leaders have made that clear and we've
got a good deal this is a deal that is
good for the United Kingdom
as a whole that allows us to keep take
control of fishing that takes our
agriculture alter the very unpopular
Common Agricultural Policy that allows
us to have close security links with
Europe but also to respect the trading
links that we need so this is a good
deal it's one that respects the United
Kingdom it gives our businesses the
certainty to protect jobs the jobs of
your viewers and the alternative as
European leaders have made after what
has been a very difficult and intense
two years of negotiation is that this is
the only deal on the table and
parliamentarians really need to reflect
on the uncertainty that would result
from not supporting a deal that respects
the referendum and there's nothing I
just want to be I just want to be
absolutely clear mr. Bartlett because I
don't want anyone to misinterpret your
remarks just the same question again you
mentioned no deal there
if the Commons says no to the deal
that's on the table
No Deal is the alternative that is what
will happen that is what you are saying
no what I'm saying is we will be
uncertain there'll be no deal or no
bricks it there isn't an alternative
deal on the table from the European
Union it's taken us two years a very
tough negotiation to get to this point
and we need to give businesses the
certainty we need to give our citizens
the certainty that this deal will do and
this is a deal that as I say allows us
to create control of our own immigration
of our borders to have a skin
based immigration system to have a
independent coastal policy to take our
agriculture out of the common
agricultural policy to take back control
of our money borders and laws and it's
about time we get that certainty and
bring the Commission together after what
has been a very divisive two years
haven't given that mrs. mate the people
that mrs. may really needs to convince
more than anyone else up there are the
MPS out of comment a she embarking on
this kind of tour around the aisles to
try and sell this to the public in fact
more than that why is she trying to
persuade the public of the merit in this
when they don't have a vote on it well I
think we need to do both we need to take
the message to the public and also to
MPs but and bees themselves gave this
decision to the public MPs voted to have
a referendum to give the public a say
and so it's quite right that we take our
case to the public it was their vote the
biggest Democratic decision in our
country's history the people had their
say and I think it's quite right that a
people then hear from the Prime Minister
on the merits of the deal it's a deal
that delivers on the vote that the
people themselves made the biggest vote
in our history in the referendum and
it's right that we make our case to
those who voted in it a busy few weeks
ahead for you no doubt so at many thanks
for taking the time to talk to us thank
you actually thanks being with us